[Music]
all is all this
stuff tails and I will go left up along
the
ridge you really think you can keep up
with me been doing it all day if you
can't keep up just go with them one of
these days I am going to knock you out
really W you're definitely not at the
beach
anymore can say that
again well we are definitely not at the
beach anymore
hey there are things inside these
things should have seen that
coming no turning back now you ready for
this I was going to ask you that are you
ready snakes I hate
snakes this is why they call me
knuckles
and more
snakes
[Music]
burrowing what's the score
Sonic
all right how do we open the
gate we won't be able to budge that
ourselves let's use the enter beam and
try and move it into
place that actually
worked
I think the Mine card is the key
[Music]
here bouncy
bouncy